者数
ず社長です次に
02/14メックスるー
深夜徘徊を始めます
続質問です夜の公園北好きなんすよ
分かってこの関税等とまずね夜が声の素晴らしさを教えてあげよう
い
goo
おっん
とって
me
うん数
えっえっえっ
います
聞こえますか蝉が鳴いています公園のライトの明かりを朝と間違えてないているの
でしょ
大馬鹿ものです
うん
はいこんにちはんじゃないこんばんは1月の22日月曜日は
ん
土用の丑の日なんでん
ローソンで注文した
ううなじゅううなぎ弁当ってゆうなぎ綿と麻
夜の公園で
一人こっそり食べようと思います不審者ですよモッチーねここまで不審者をまで来たら
まずそもそもと色の丑の日って何なんでしょうね
そっからまず教えてほしいです上甲にょいいっていうかこんなんですっっ
表
いただきますちょっと何で土用の丑の日っていうか何かコメントで教えていただくと
ありがたいです
4つ
甘い動かさ花嫌いなんですよ寿司屋で言えて食べるのがネットサーモンなんですけど
めっちゃこうしたん
うなぎは食べれます曽我ローソン北の話になるんですけど8位だっつの
8月乃兎
2寸ぐらいにちょっと僕一回ローソンちょっとおりますんで
何にしようかなローソン終わったら商品紹介続けるか全く違うことするかちょっとまた
迷うとこなんですけど
さあ考えてみますとうん
ローソンは
本当にいいコンビんだよ
入って思ったけど
osc しパンとか
本当に何かお世辞とかじゃないですようっ手間と金とまぁなくもう心の底から結構好き
なんで
なんかねほんとに俺をキック現地てうん
みんなローソン
行く機会増えたらいいなって思いますね
う姫武者がじゃないこの呼ばさを表現します
いい
ん
ポッ
う前
ああああああ
ああ
夜なんで本当に声だしちゃダメなんで
そこら辺ご理解のほどお願いしますあっあーっ
はっはっは
ああああああっ
ぜひねー
土用の丑の日意味はわからないんですけどうなぎ食べようじゃな
ん
me
うん